>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Ralph Ehrenberg:
I am Ralph Ehrenberg,
chief of the geography
and map division.
It is my great pleasure to welcome
you here to the Library today
for our two-day conference on Facts
or Fictions, Debating the Mysteries
of Early Modern Science
and Cartography,
which is being sponsored
by the Jay I.
Kislak Family Foundation and the
Virginia Gray Family Memorial Fund.
This conference was
planned and organized
by Dr. John Hessler,
curator of the Jay I.
Kislak collection of archaeology
and history of the early Americas
at the Library of Congress,
and John is also the geography
and map division specialist
in modern cartography
and geographic information systems.
The subtitle of our conference is
a celebration of 500th anniversary
of Waldseemuller's
1516 Carta Marina.
I'd like to comment briefly on the
Library's acquisition of this chart,
one of the great masterpieces
of Renaissance mapping.
Shortly after its publication,
our copy of this map was acquired
by Johann Schoner [phonetic],
a noted Nuremberg mathematician
and geographer, who bound
it together with a number
of globe gores drawn by him,
the earliest printed star chart
of the southern hemisphere
engraved by Albrecht Durer,
and Waldseemuller's other famous map
is 1507 Universalis Cosmographia,
the map that named America.
With the recent acquisition
of Durer's star chart,
the Library of Congress has
now brought back together all
of the maps and charts that
were originally contained
in Schoner's bound portfolio now
known as the Schoner's [inaudible].
This portfolio was
unknown to the wider world
for some 350 years although
Washington Irving's research in 1828
on the origin of the name America
cited Waldseemuller's 1507 map.
German geographer Alexander
von Humboldt later alluded
to Irving's work, stimulating
a further search for the map.
No copies were found,
however, until 1901,
when the Austrian Jesuit scholar,
Josef Fischer, who we'll hear more
about shortly, located
this map while searching
for material relating to the early
Norse voyages to North America.
It was found in the
Waldburg-Wolfegg family castle
in south central Germany.
Fortunately, this family
had provided a safe haven
through three centuries of numerous
wars and political upheavals.
As early as 1912, Prince
Johannes Waldburg-Wolfegg offered
Waldseemuller's 1507 map
to the Library of Congress
where he believed it would be more
readily available for research
on display, but limited resources
prevented its purchase at that time.
In 1977, the chief of the
geography division at that time,
Walter W. Ristow, viewed
the Schoner portfolio
at the castle during a visit
with Count Maxwell
Wilbrod [phonetic] Walburg.
Six years later, the
Schoner portfolio was loaned
to the Smithsonian Institution's
National Museum of American History
for exhibition focusing
on the naming of America.
The centerpiece of this exhibition
was Waldseemuller's 1507 map
with one sheet of the map displayed
at a time most frequently the one
contained in the name America.
The Schoner portfolio made a return
visit to the nation's capital
in 1992 during the Columbus
quincentenary celebration.
On that occasion, the Folger
Shakespeare Library's conservation
staff removed the 12 woodcut
map plates of the 1507 map
from its portfolio, binding and
reassembling them as a wall map
for the first time for display
in the National Gallery of Art.
Former Librarian of Congress James
Billington began discussing during
this period with Count
Johannes Walburg
about acquiring the 1507 map.
It was purchased in 2003 with a $5
million appropriation from Congress
and matching funds
generously donated
by George Topolowski
[phonetic], Virginia Gray,
Gerald Landfest [phonetic],
David Kauf [phonetic],
and the Discovery Channel.
German Chancellor Angela Merkel
formally transferred this treasure
to the American people
in an official ceremony
in the Thomas Jefferson
building in 2007.
Waldseemuller's 1516 Carta Marina,
the subject of our work today,
was later purchased by Jay I.
Kislak along with the rest
of Schoner's portfolio,
which included Schoner's
important celestial
and terrestrial globe gores.
Mr. Kislak then arranged for
the donation of the Carta Marina
and the globe gores to the
Library of Congress along
with his monumental
American Collection.
Durer's star chart was acquired late
last year with appropriated funds,
which added the final piece that
compromised Schoner's [inaudible].
Thanks to the dedication and the
public spirit of these donors,
Schoner's portfolio with
Waldseemuller's two master maps,
Schoner's globe gores, and Durer's
star chart will remain together,
available for future generations
for examination and study.
Waldseemuller's 1507 map is on
permanent display in this bleeding
in the second floor gallery
along with Durer's star chart.
The Schoner portfolio with the 1516
map will be on display tomorrow
in the geography and map division,
which is located in the basement
of the Madison building across
the street and will be on display
from one to three in the afternoon
along with other treasures
from the map division ranging from
Porterlain [phonetic] charts dating
from the 13th century to maps
by George Washington
and Lewis and Clark.
For those of you who aren't familiar
with the geography and map division,
the division holds
the world's largest
and most comprehensive
map collection,
numbering some 5-1/2 million
maps and 80,000 atlases.
We are open to the public for
research from Monday through Friday
from 8:30 in the morning
until 5 in the afternoon.
Established in 1897 as the
Hall of Maps to serve Congress
and federal agencies, the geography
and map division today functions
as a national map library.
It's primary responsibility
is developing the Library's
cartographic collections.
An average of some 40,000
items are acquired yearly
through government deposits,
transfers of superseded maps
from federal libraries,
copyright deposits, domestic
and international exchanges,
purchases, and gifts.
These range from rare globes and
maps to geospatial data sets.
Our cartographic collection is dated
as I said from the 13th century
and covers virtually all
countries and subjects.
While many of the current items
are acquired through exchange
and deposits, the division relies
heavily on donors to assist
in the acquisition of rare
maps and unique collections.
In 1995, we established
a public support group,
the Philip Lee Phillips Map
Society of the Library of Congress
for those persons who wished to
support the work of the division.
The Phillips Society
issues four newsletters
and two occasional papers yearly.
A copy of our most recent newsletter
is available at the foyer,
and I hope these were passed
out to you when you came in.
If you wish to add your name to our
mailing list, please contact any
of our staff members
who are in the foyer.
And now it's my pleasure to turn
the podium over to Dr. John Hessler,
who will begin a formal
program today.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well, I want
to extend the same welcome
that Ralph did to everyone.
Welcome to the Library of Congress.
We've got kind of a
two-part program today.
The first part has got a title
called Facts or Fictions,
the Mysteries of Renaissance
and early cartography.
Now, the reason we kind of
paired these two things together,
an afternoon on the 1516
Carta Marina and the mysteries
of other maps of the
period is simply
because the Waldseemuller maps are
also a rather large cartographic
mystery, and so we thought we
would put in one room a number
of scholars who've been working on
some of these difficult problems
in the history of cartography,
everything from Marco Polo maps all
the way to the 1516 Carta Marina,
which I believe Chet is going to
actually solve all the problems
about today, so he's
been working on it.
One thing I want to
do before we begin
and before I introduce our
first speaker is I want
to thank Ralph Ehrenberg for his
service to the Library of Congress
as chief of the geography
and map division.
Ralph will be retiring sometime
in the next few months after years
and years of service
to this institution
to the national archives
and to this discipline.
When I was a young student,
when I was an undergraduate,
I had the opportunity to get a
fellowship at the Vatican Library
in Rome and actually at the
Vatican Observatory Library,
and there I met a man whose name
was Pietro Tucci [phonetic].
Pietro Tucci was a 92-year-old
librarian who believed
that doing his job, being a rare
book librarian, being a librarian
of science was one of
the highest callings.
I appeared on his doorstep
as a very young man of 19.
He wasn't used to having
19-year-old Americans
through the Vatican
Observatory Library.
As a matter of fact, in the
three months I was there,
I only saw one other human
being besides Pietro Tucci.
But Pietro Tucci warmed
me and at one point
in time he called me
back to the stacks.
And he said, young man, I
want to teach you something.
I want to show you something
that is more important
than the work you are doing.
You're a scholar.
You're looking at these
books, but let's walk
down through these stacks.
And he walked down
through these stacks,
and occasionally he would pull
a book off the shelf and say,
this person collected this.
This was put up here
by this librarian.
And Pietro Tucci had
come through the war.
He was an Italian priest of
Polish extraction who had come
through the war, and Pietro
Tucci wanted me to know that one
of the most important things
about doing this work is the fact
that a book standing freely on
a shelf in an open library was
for him the difference
between lightness and darkness,
between goodness and evil.
And he said to me there were
very few people in the world
who knew this, who practiced this,
who thought this was the purpose
of a library, that this entire
enterprise was the difference
between, and he called
it, humanities last stand.
In my 35-year career of doing this
I have met few people who could come
up to Pietro Tucci's standard.
One of those people
is Ralph Ehrenberg,
a man who as I said has dedicated
his life to this institution
and to the history of
cartography, and I just want
to congratulate Ralph
on his retirement.
[ Applause ]
And with that, I will introduce
our first speaker, Kirsten Seaver.
Most of the people in this
audience who are involved
in the early history of cartography,
she would need no introduction
as she is at least to me somewhat
of a legend in this field.
She is a historian of
the Norse of Greenland,
the history of the North Atlantic.
She has written many novels.
She has traveled widely,
participated in many documentary
films, and her novelistic talent,
her talent for writing
novels I think goes deep
down into her scholarly work.
She is one of the few people,
I think, who have actively
and intensely studied the
relationship of Josef Fischer,
the Norse, and the maps that we
are going to talk about today.
So without further ado, I would
like to introduce Kirsten Seaver.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> Kirsten Seaver: Thank you, John,
for that wonderful introduction.
I was swelling as I was listening
to you, or at least my head was.
It's a pleasure to be here
tonight, or this morning rather.
I am confused because I just came
in from California last night,
and it really is a good cause
because this is a fantastic thing
to celebrate, having
these maps here.
Father Josef Fischer, S.J.,
the Arodite [phonetic] German
and Austrian cartographic
historian, who discovered the 1507
and 1516 Waldseemuller maps
at Wolfegg castle in 1901,
some decade later became
the likely author
of Yale's controversial Vinland map.
And that situation appeared
so incongruous that I want
to talk this morning
about some of the maps
and ideas I believe
inspired both events.
[ Background Noise ]
Although at the time of his Wolfegg
sojourn, Father Fischer was working
on his MA thesis for
the-- better, okay?
Everybody can hear me now?
At the time of his Wolfegg
sojourn, Father Fischer was working
on his MA thesis for the
cartographic historian
and geographer Franz von
Wieser, who had convinced him
that early cartographic
evidence existed
for the Norse westward expeditions
from the recently settled
Greenland colonies
to the North America
around the year 1000.
In the aftermath of
the 400th anniversary
of the Columbian discovery, the
region the Norse called Vinland
or wine land was the southernmost
of the three American areas
that the Norse had explored,
and it was the only one
that interested von
Wieser, Fischer, and others.
Although Vinland's demographic
extent is in fact unknowable except
as an area that included
Newfoundland
and the southern St. Lawrence
[inaudible], Fischer was sure
that it consisted of Nova Scotia
and Cape Britain combined,
and he was equally certain that
the climate a thousand years
or so ago was so warm that the Norse
had traveled up both the coasts
of Greenland and learned their
country's essential shape.
He reasoned that all maps showing
Greenland would also reveal the rest
of the Norse westward exploits
as such maps must have a
uniquely German lineage rooted
in Adam O'Bramen's [phonetic]
11th century references
to the Norse presence in
Iceland, Greenland, and Vinland.
And he hoped to find further
evidence for his theories
at Wolfegg castle, a baroque
jewel in Baden-Wurttemberg
with a magnificent collection
of art objects [inaudible],
manuscript texts, and maps.
He would not have far to travel, nor
did he need a formal introduction
because Wolfegg's noble
owners, the Catholic family
of Altberg [phonetic], Wolfegg
habitually sent their sons
to be educated at Stella
Matutina, the Catholic school
in the Austrian border
town of Feldkirch
where Fischer was teaching
geography and history.
In 1901, he wrote to the
castle librarian and asked
if the collections might include
a manuscript map showing Greenland
as a European peninsula
in the manner of 1482
and 1486 Olm [phonetic]
geography in the Olm editions.
And the librarian reported back
that the search had
yielded a manuscript map
by Donnes Nicholas
Gamonis [phonetic]
that might meet Fischer's
requirements.
Fischer soon identified the Nicholas
Gamonis manuscript as the prototype
of printed maps in the Olm
editions where Greenland
and the so-called B [phonetic]
reduction is depicted as a large,
blunt peninsula east of Iceland and
connected to Eurasia above Norway.
He and von Wieser were already
familiar with the manuscript maps,
which the Benedictine
monk, Nicholas Gamonis,
had drawn for the so-called
Zamweskee [phonetic] codex
of circa 1467, and edition
of Ptolemy's Geographia,
which had strengthened
the two scholars' belief
that cartographic evidence of
Norse exploration westward must
have existed.
The Zamweskee version
shows Greenland
as a pointed peninsula west of
Iceland in the so-called A reduction
but also linked above Norway
to northwestern Eurasia
and like the Wolfegg manuscript
indicated a second Greenland
where Norway meets
Sweden in the north.
Continuing his searches in the
castle library, Fischer discovered,
as we have heard, Waldseemuller's
printed world map of 1507
and the Carta Marina of 1516 in
a bound volume miscellany owned
by the Nuremberg mathematician
Johannes Schoner.
As an expert on Ptolemaic maps
of the 15th and 16th centuries,
Fischer was well equipped to
identify the Waldseemuller maps.
The German academic educate required
that his thesis advisor
verify the discoveries,
so in the joint analysis
was published in 1903,
von Wieser's name joined
Fischer's on the title page.
In a book that Fischer
published in his own name in 1902
and which appeared in
English the following year,
he enthusiastically reviewed the
cartographic connections he had made
at Wolfegg and wrote, this lucky
discovery was remarkable if only
for its bearing on the discoveries
made by the Norsemen as well
as on the relation to
the later discoveries
of Columbus and his successors.
Prior to 1901, the 1520 Petrus
Apianus world map was considered the
oldest surviving printed
map using the name America.
Waldseemuller's 1507 map
was known to have existed
but was believed lost until
Fischer found a surviving example
at Wolfegg.
The 1507 map additionally rewarded
him with a prominent Greenland,
shaped and positioned as in the
Wolfegg Nicholas Garmonis manuscript
and the printed Olm maps and linking
to the Eurasian continent
north of Norway.
Waldseemuller did not
repeat the name America
when he made his magnificent
Carta Marina in 1516,
but like it's 1507 predecessor,
it featured a large peninsular
Greenland linked to Norway.
Moreover, like all the
other maps mentioned so far,
it had a second Greenland where
northern Norway and Sweden met
and provided similar place names
on the larger Greenland peninsula.
Fischer felt confident that all
these features were directly related
to the work that the Danish cleric
Claudius Clavus did sometime
between 1424 and 1427 for inclusion
with cardinal Gion Feastrus
[phonetic] manuscript copy
of Ptolemy Geographia, and the
connection is there but not quite
in the way that Fischer imagined.
The Clavus map of the north,
which the French scholar Jon Lorr
[phonetic] discovered at [inaudible]
in 1835 is the first known
cartographic representation
of Greenland.
Here it is shown as the east coast
of a peninsula called
Greenlandia Provincia [phonetic]
and connected eastward
to the Eurasian mainland via
the Scandinavian peninsula.
Because Fischer credited Clavus
with envisioning a continuous
circumpolar continent,
he considered the [inaudible] map
the first map to also show America.
An opinion he developed fully in
1911, unaware that Norse activities
that far west had long been so
murky in the Danish consciousness
that Clavus had mistakenly
relegated the Norse
to the Greenland's east
coast [inaudible] west.
Ptolemy for his part had never
referred to Greenland by any name.
Therefore, Blor [phonetic]
considered both the Clavus map
and a short companion text
worthy of special attention,
particularly given that both
items were in a hand different
from that anywhere
else in the codex,
and both employ the Danish letter o/
that is O with a slash rather than O
with an umloute [phonetic].
And these peculiarities
suggested to Blor
that Fiasta [phonetic] had
commissioned somebody quite well
informed about these remote northern
regions, in other words that the map
and the text were the personal work
of Claudius Clavus as
claimed on the map.
And Blor was right.
The O with slash implied
only in Norwegian
and Danish is used correctly
throughout the map and text
with a consistency that no French
or Italian copies would
have been likely to manage,
and by the way I am a
native Norwegian speaker.
There are also numerous
other indications
that Clavus had made the map
and the texts specifically
for the cardinal's Geographia.
Nonetheless, this agreement with
Blor arose in 1835, 45 rather,
when the German scholar Gee Vites
[phonetic] blindly ignoring the O
with a slash, doubted that the map
and the text were personal
work of Claudius Clavus.
[Inaudible] believed that both the
map and the text were anonymous
and inferior copies of Clavus
originals was soon joined
by an equally persistent
and wrong-headed conviction
that post 1427 Clavus had made
an improved version of the map
that had also followed
Ptolemaic precepts closely
but that later maps unfortunately
was lost and could not be consulted.
Huh, where have we
heard that one before?
Clavus had left Denmark for
the European mainland before,
or around I should say, 1413
or 14, just when Ptolemy system
of coordinates was
embraced farther south
but had not yet reached Denmark.
[ Background Noise ]
Airplane throat.
Had not yet reached Denmark,
but the Danish cleric was
obviously a very quick learner
because only a decade or so after
leaving home he based his map
and text for Feastrus manuscript
on Ptolemy systems of coordinates
as well as unfamiliarity with
the works of Adam O'Bramen
and [inaudible] and on what he
knew personally about the geography
of his northern home region.
[ Background Noise ]
While he knew from Adam O'Bramen's
history that Greenland lay west
of Iceland, his grasp on Denmark's
Scandinavian neighbors failed him
beyond the Dovre mountains in
Norway, and he had difficulties
with Norwegian and
Swedish [inaudible].
Only one such problem
concerns us here.
On the Feaster [phonetic] map
but not on the accompanying text,
Clavus wrote [foreign language]
where northern Sweden joins Norway.
And that became the second Greenland
on both the A and the B reductions
in Nicholas Garmonis' manuscript
maps and their successors.
The known whereabouts of
Feastrus' Geographia between 1427
and 1835 show that the codex
could not have been seen
by Nicholas Garmonis but by 1467,
he had nevertheless
acquired information
that inspired both his twin
Greenlands and his experiments
with the country's shape, it's
nomenclature, and it's placement.
We must look for an explanation in
the context that Clavus is known
to have had with continental
scholars and in notes
and sketches necessarily made in
preparation for Feastrus' codex.
Alas, the whereabouts of any
such material is as unknown
as the ultimate fate
of Clavus himself,
but a trail suggesting
a Benedictine network
and containing many later
interpolations has yielded nuggets
of additional information that
could only have originated
with Clavus although his own
affiliations were [inaudible].
Next, a fantasy about an improved
companion text joined the notion
that Clavus had laid a second
and improved map in 1904
when the Danish scholar
Oxlong von Burenbul [phonetic]
and Carles Pietrus [phonetic]
published the interpretations
of two 16th century manuscripts they
had discovered at the Royal Library
of Vienna and called
the Vienna text.
They argued that travels in
Greenland and other Nordic countries
after 1427 had enable Clavus
to produce both a second map
and an improved text that became the
prototype of the two Vienna texts
and from which excerpts
had been published in 1515
by Johannes Schoner and in 1518
by Francisco Zerenicus [phonetic].
As soon as Burenbul and
Pietrus' book was out,
Fischer began a correspondence
with Burenbul that lasted
until the latter's death.
He immediately assured his Danish
colleague of his own belief
that Clavus had personal
knowledge of Greenland,
a conviction he still held
when Burenbul died in 1911
without revealing to Fischer
that the Norwegian explorer Fetuv
Nonsen [phonetic] was certain
that Clavus had never
been to Greenland.
In a short monograph on Clavus that
Fischer published that same year
in 1911, he insisted that Clavus
had explored up the Greenland coast
as far as 70 degrees 2 second
northward, northern latitude.
Because of his inability
to read either the primary
or secondary material in Nordic
languages, plus his tendency
to rather rigid thinking,
Fischer maintained his belief
in the post 1427 information
by Clavus had provided
Nicholas Garmonis
with information about Greenland.
When starting his thesis
research on the medieval Norse,
Fischer had relied on help from the
Norwegian historian Gustuv Steim
[phonetic], but Steim died in 1906,
and with Burenbul's death in 1911,
Fischer lost his remaining
source of Nordic collegial help.
He did nothing with his beloved
Norse from 1911 until 1932
when he was 74 years old, and
the Swiss Austrian auction firm
of Gilhof Antrantsburg
[phonetic] asked him
to analyze a manuscript copied
from early Ptolemy Geographia.
The volume's regional map of
Greenland, which reminded him
of Ausmiller's [phonetic] Greenland
in the 1513 Strassberg Geographia,
brought all his former
preoccupations back in full force.
The Gilhof Antrantsburg
auction catalog
for 1934 featured both
the Geographia codex
with Fischer's analysis and
selected items from the library
of Mikulov [phonetic]
castle in Moravia,
a collection with which
Fischer was as familiar
as with the auction house.
[ Background Noise ]
While the Library contained
damaged as well as undamaged items,
the [inaudible] were excluded from
the auction catalog but a fragment
of the Speculum Historiale
by Vincent Aubove [phonetic]
was acceptable
because Mikulov had provided
it with a new binding,
and it was in generally good
condition except for leaves seven
through 12, which had
been damaged by a nail.
Interestingly, that fragment
represented the book following
immediately after the four
Speculum books that ended up at Yale
in association with the Vinland map.
[ Background Noise ]
On October 11, 1965, Yale
University Library announced
that it possessed an unnamed
manuscript from about 1440
that depicted the Norse
discovery of America.
The item was dubbed the Vinland map
because in the northwestern
Atlantic it showed a large island
with two legends calling
the island Vinelanda insula.
On that same day, Yale University
Press launched the Vinland map
and the [inaudible] relation
by R.A. Skelton [phonetic],
Thomas Marsten [phonetic], and
George Painter to authenticate
and describe the map and
the formerly unknown version
of Friar John de Plano Carpini's
[phonetic] account of his 1245
to 47 embassy to the
great Kahn [phonetic],
the so-called tarter [phonetic]
relation bound with the map
at the time of purchase
in Switzerland.
Four dilapidated books of
the Speculum Historiale
in a comparatively modern binding
had turned up a little later
as a sister manuscript to the map.
No existing cartographic record of
Vinland was known not surprisingly,
since the medieval Norse
neither used nor made maps.
Therefore, it's appearance
on otherwise conventional medieval
world map was remarkable indeed.
However, the Vinland map
is a demonstrable fake,
and like any other
artifact, fake or genuine,
it reflects its maker's
preoccupations and environment.
In 1974, the map's ink was found
to continue anatase crystals
of a kind first available
commercially around 1920,
and analysis was confirmed in 2002.
Amazingly, this did not settle
the authenticity issue with those
of the map's defenders unable to
grasp that the additional historical
and cartographic evidence
shows that this work
in no way reflects Norse
geographical knowledge.
Instead, it illustrates the 19th
century preoccupation with England,
and that times mistaken belief
that the Norse experience
with North American had
been a very short duration.
Unfortunately, Skelton and
Marsten and Painter knew as little
about the history and culture
of the medieval Norse as the man
who had made the map and left
footprints so idiosyncratic
that there is no mistaking
who's they are.
The shorter of the two legends
near the island of Vinland says,
island of Vinland discovered
by Bjarni and Leif and company.
Well, the very first time that
Leif and Bjarni sailed off
to America together and discovered
Vinland, that was Leif Eiriksson
and Bjarni Hyalson [phonetic]
and that was in 1765.
In the history of [inaudible]
Greenland
by the German [inaudible]
David Grantz [phonetic]
who had simply misread
Paul Ava Malay's [phonetic]
[foreign language].
Grantz' book appears
in the bibliography
of the 1903 English translation of
Fischer's book on the Norse voyages
to America, which had
a contorted explanation
for the Icelandic [inaudible]
agreement
on who had first discovered America.
In addition, sharing
his Ausmiller triumph
with von Wieser had made Fischer
receptive to a broader definition
of joint discovery, and his hero,
Adam O'Bramen, to whom both Vinland
and Greenland were
islands had written
that Vinland was an island
"discovered by many."
The longer legend's description
of the land which byarnus
and leiphus erissonius
discovered together,
"a new land extremely fertile
and even having vines" echos
Adam O'Bramen's statement
that Vinland got its name because
"vines producing excellent wine grow
wild there" along the unsewn crops.
The same legend also reveals
Fischer's tin ear for German names,
non-German names, and his
unease with the suffix -son.
He invariably referred to Leif
Eiriksson as the son of Eirik
in his publications, and on the
Vinland map the name is Latinized
to leiphus erissonius
as you can see.
Understandably, he gave
up on a Latin patrolimic
[phonetic] for Bjarni Hyalson.
Henricus [inaudible]
bishop [inaudible]
of Greenland is straightforward
but dating his arrival in Vinland
to "the last year of our
most blessed Father Pascal,"
whose papal reign was from 1099
to 1118 is not straightforward.
In fact, this entire legend is part
of a complex riddle and reveals
that the map's purpose is to
demonstrate that emissaries
of the Roman church had succeeded
in circumnavigating the
inhabited world at an early age.
When Bishop Eric proceeded
to "wintery east" it was
in the Columbian sense of to the
east, that is even so far west
from proto [phonetic] America
that he gained the farthest east
and thus completed the circle.
[ Background Noise ]
Father Fischer, a man of
immense rectitude and devotion
to his church would have been
appalled by the later use made
of the map he drew in the 1930's
as a private catharsis
during a difficult time.
Being then old and frail,
he had reason to believe
that if the map turned
up after his death,
it would confront German
Nazi culture bearers
with a difficult choice.
If they denied the early reach
of the despised Catholic church
and pronounced the map a fake,
they would miss an opportunity
to use the Norse discovery
of America as an argument
for expanding the Aryan Third
Reich right to our own shores.
In 1944, Fischer died
at Wolfegg castle
where he had been given
refuge during World War II.
He was 86 years old.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> John Hessler: Just in a word
of format, we're going to go
through all the speakers,
and then we'll sit together
and have questions from
the audience as a group.
Our next speaker, Ben Olshin, is
one of those people who have come
to the history of cartography
with a multitalented
and multifaceted background.
Ben both studies classics
and design,
which really makes him perfect for
studying the history of cartography.
He is a professor of the school
of the arts in Philadelphia,
has taught widely all over the
world, and has written a book
on what have been called
the Marco Polo maps.
One of those maps called the
Rossi map with Ship reside
in the geography and map
division, and it will be on display
at the open house tomorrow.
These are maps that have always
had real questions associated
with them and the family.
Many scholars have dismissed them,
but Ben has really written a book
that brings these maps alive and
back into the scholarly discussion
in a measured and really
intellectual way.
So, Ben--
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> Ben Olshin: First of all,
I'd like to thank the Library
of Congress for inviting me and
despite the very kind introduction,
I'm actually rather humbled.
As I was sitting there,
I looked over there,
and I saw Chet Van Dusser,
and I sort of metaphorically
tipped my hat.
That's real scholarship there, and
Hester himself is a real scholar,
and obviously Seaver as well.
So you might say I
bring many talents.
You could also just say I'm
and amateur and a dabbler,
so it's really up to you.
The other thing I wanted
to say today is
that this is not a
book promotion talk,
but I do want to draw your attention
to the book because many questions
that people might have are
addressed in the book itself,
and so what I'm going to talk
about today refers to the contents
of the book, but you
should read the book.
And I'm going to talk a little bit,
you notice the title is different
from what you might see in
your program, I want to talk
about methods and analysis, which
in a way is sort of a nice segue
from the proceeding talk as well.
What do you do when you're faced
with something like the Vinland map
or like these Rossi maps?
However, I want to start
even before then to talk
about the book a little bit.
My father, who is a pediatrician,
and there's another speaker
who is also a pediatrician who likes
maps, my father is a pediatrician
who gave many talks, and all
pediatricians have a sense of humor.
And he said you cannot give
a lecture without some humor
at the beginning, and so I thought
about that, and I was lecturing
at Oxford in April, and my
wife, who is an accountant,
which is the exact opposite,
said do not make jokes
at the beginning of
a talk at Oxford.
So I ignored her and
listened to my father,
and I want to tell the audience, you
know, why should you buy this book
if you haven't bought it already,
and I just want to show you
because if you don't buy
it, my child will go hungry
because of low book sales, so--
I asked my daughter to
pose for that photograph.
I also like to point out that sort
of in retrospect it was strange.
I gave a talk once, and somebody
came up to me, and they said,
well you speak Italian and you speak
Chinese, did you draw these maps?
And I said, no, no.
But it seems like I'm
sort of a Marco Polo,
and I dug up this photo of me.
This is probably from about 15
years ago, and it's me with my wife,
who is from the Far East,
and we're standing in front
of the Colosseum in Rome.
So I like to think that I'm a Marco
Polo although the Netflix series did
not contract me for some reason.
So let me talk a little bit about
the research methods because I think
for an audience like this that's
a mix of map scholars and people
who are interested in maps,
it's kind of insightful
to see what do you do again when
faced with material like this.
We don't really know a
lot about Marco Polo.
He is so famous that he has a TV
series based on him, but ironically
for a figure like this,
we don't really have
that much material evidence.
We have his last will and
testament, which has survived.
We have a few other documents,
and then oddly there's this
Rossi Collection as it's called
of about 13 or 14 documents
related to him.
But really the primary
document that we do know of is
of course his narrative, Il
Milione, as it's called in Italian,
and there are multiple
manuscripts of this Il Milione
in different languages,
and we know for example
that Marco Polo's text was read by
Christopher Columbus and annotated
by him, so it's interesting.
On the one hand, we have a
very well-established history
of Marco Polo, of his
narrative that's very clear,
but what gets puzzling is
when we try to take that
and connect it with maps.
Maps and charts are hardly
mentioned in the narrative at all,
and if you pick up a translation
of the narrative of Marco Polo,
you find that it's very
difficult to draw a map.
It's very vague in terms of how
it refers to different locations,
to different parts of his travels,
but if you get a nice 19th
century edition and open it up,
you'll see these beautiful
maps with little dotted lines
as if you could read it and actually
plot a trip, and you cannot.
And that's one of the puzzles.
It's made some people doubt that
Marco Polo went on these voyages,
and then becomes even more
puzzling when suddenly we're told
that there's actually a series of
maps connected with Marco Polo.
So as Hessler said, it's
called the Rossi Collection,
and the reason it's called the Rossi
Collection is because of this man,
Filomeno Emmanuele Marciano Rossi,
who was an Italian immigrant
who came originally to
St. Louis and then ended
up in San Jose, California.
He brought with him probably on more
than one trip a collection of maps,
texts, and letters, and
the material likely ranges
from the 13th to the 18th century.
What's interesting is
the maps themselves.
I'll show you some examples, because
they contain a very odd mixture
of Arabic, Chinese,
Latin, and Italian,
and very little study was
done of these, partly probably
because they seem kind of a
fringe element of cartography,
partly because they're such an odd
range of subject matter within them.
Leo Bagrow, the very famous
historian of cartography,
wrote really the only published
scholarly article in the 1940's
about them, and nothing
was really done since then,
and then the Library of
Congress still holds one map.
They possessed some of
the other maps for a time.
They did an internal study, but
nothing was really published.
And then I came upon
these around 1999.
I had moved back to the states,
and I tracked down the owner,
and I got access to them.
And I was really intrigued, but from
the perspective of a researcher,
what I think is so interesting is
the range of knowledge that one has
to bring to bear, and I
would be the last to say
that I have all this knowledge,
but I'd like to point out,
just in terms of methodology,
what does one have
to know to attack these maps.
Again, Latin, Italian,
Chinese, as I'll show you.
You have to know the context
about ancient and medieval maps.
You have to know about Ptolemy
and similar maps from the period.
You have to know about Marco
Polo himself, his narrative,
the tradition of the manuscripts,
of the Marco Polo narrative.
You have to know the general history
of central Asia, east Asia, Europe.
You have to know as I found
out later, Chinese legends
because there's a Chinese legend
connected to one of the maps.
And then you have to know about
velums and inks and carbon dating,
which I know much less about
and still up for discussion.
And then you have to
know about the history
of forgeries, which is fascinating.
You just heard about the Vinland map
and the motivations
for a possible forger.
So let's look at some
of the maps themselves.
I'm going to pick a few
because they have some
of the more interesting features.
This is called the Moreta Polo map,
and most of the maps have
an apparent signature
by one of the daughters.
Marco Polo was very lucky
as am I to have daughters,
and he had three daughters, and
this is in fact well documented.
Seeing them connected with
cartography is quite peculiar
of course, but this is one of
the maps, the Moreta Polo map,
and anyone that's done history
of cartography can immediately
see this is a very strange piece
of work.
It has gridlines like Ptolemy, but
the depictions of the continents
and the whole system
is very strange,
and it has these odd columns with
the number seven at the bottom
and what looks like a
Chinese seven at the top.
It's not really clear, and then
a very long inscription along
the bottom.
What's interesting then too
is what the inscription says.
Very matter of factly it
says in English translation,
journey made by Maffeo Nicholau
and Marco Polo from Venice to Acre
in Persia, from Acra finally
to Campalu in Tartary,
voyaging through valleys
and mountains,
Marco Polo drew a summu nauticu,
kind of a nautical summary,
and navigated the sea up to the
eastern extremity, whatever that is,
and finally a long peninsula
completely surrounded by sea wolves,
luvi marini, and connected to a huge
land completely unknown, hint, hint.
So it's very strange.
You know, it's very strange
because in a way unlike the Vinland
map it makes no explicit claim.
It's kind of an implied claim, and
it's just very peculiar to see a map
with this text, with
these depictions.
And what struck me in particular
about this collection is
that it's a collection.
There's more than one piece,
and they sort of relate
to each other but they don't.
As I'll point out at the end
of the talk, the Vinland map
to me is fascinating
because it's a one-of.
It's a single creation.
These are multiple creations.
This one's called the Sirdomap
Chart because it refers
to what's terms a Syrian
navigator, so an Arab
or Islamic navigator named
Sirdomab or Sirdomap.
It's spelled differently
in two ways.
And again already you see
very strange setup here
where there is a map or chart.
There's Arabic.
There are Roman numerals, and
then there's a text below.
And again it's all
about northeastern Asia,
the furthest reaches of
Asia, and here we see
that the text below
is written apparently
by another daughter, Bellela Polo.
Again, Marco Polo did have
three daughters, we know that.
And this map has a set of toponyms
and then a brief text
excerpt here says, my father,
Marco Polo wishes me, Bellela,
to show this world map,
it's not a world map, which
he obtained from the pilot,
the navigator, Biaxio Sirdomap, who,
for at least thirty years sailed
the coast of Asia from Syria
to the Far East, trading
in seal skins.
And again, from a historical
perspective, this is very odd.
It's a combination of story of Marco
Polo with an account supposedly
by his daughter talking
about an Arab navigator,
talking about the extreme
northeast reaches of Asia,
about which there's no
documentation in this period.
So as a historian, I looked at
this without bias, and I was very,
very puzzled, and I
want to highlight here
in case I forget later, I had not
particular take on this in terms
of is it a forgery, what's
the voracity of this account,
but later when the book was
published, I got interviewed
by the media a great
deal, newspapers,
the Smithsonian Magazine here in DC,
and a report from the
Daily Telegraph said,
well are they real or not.
You know, that's all they want.
They just want that statement and I
said, you know, it's not about that.
For me the book is
really about the content.
I translated these.
I deciphered some of the names.
He says well what can
I quote you on?
I said, quote me that I'm the
person who looked at the content.
And he said that's very
boring, and I said, I know.
[laughter] But that's
really the purpose.
I wanted this as a
foundation for people to look
and discuss this further.
If we then analyze the content a bit
further of this chart for example,
we see again very peculiar
toponyms that again kind
of imply a certain bias within the
material itself, because if we move
across the map, we see the different
toponyms have very specific names.
The first says, peninsula de li
servi, peninsula of the Stags.
Then peninsula of the phoca
marina, which are marine seals,
and then valle conzonta e giazata,
so a connected frozen valley.
So you really get this feeling
of remote northeast Asia.
Island of women, anything Italian
has to have an island of women
of course, Isola delle Femmine.
There's a long tradition of
this mythical island of women
on cartography, and then
the gulf of the mangi,
or the manchuse [phonetic].
So what's strange again is
you have an Italian and Arabic
and it implies again a
knowledge of a region
about which we have no
documentation in this period.
This is the famous Map with
Ship, which you will get to see
if you come to the
Library of Congress.
Hessler himself has done some
work looking at writing on this
and some scratches in the
velum that also reveal writing.
This is the most famous of the maps.
If you google Rossi maps, you'll
see this because the Library
of Congress put up a very nice
high-res image, and it's also famous
because it seems to
suggest something,
which I'll highlight later.
Again, very strange.
It has a faint drawing of a ship
to the left, and apparent seal
of the Polo family, and
then the map on the right.
And I was most interested in
the map because it's an odd map,
and it has a "Chinese inscription."
It was kind of odd that I came
to this map speaking Chinese,
which was pure coincidence.
I did not write this.
One of the reasons I can tell you I
didn't write this is the characters
are not written by a
person who knows Chinese.
And this was something that had
not been pointed out before.
Chinse has what's called
a stroke order.
If you write any character,
there's a stroke order
which basically moves top
to bottom, left to right.
There's a way of writing Chinese.
If I were to hand you a Chinese menu
and say copy General Tsao's chicken
in Chinese, what it says, you
would draw the character sort
of copying the lines, and
it would look very awkward.
The proportions would be wrong.
And in fact that's
what you see here.
So whoever did this, you can
recognize the characters,
but whoever wrote this was copying
from some Chinese thing
sitting next to him or her.
So when you look at the characters
then, some of them you can make
out fairly well, and I did.
I transcribed them.
But they don't really say anything.
There's not a sentence here.
You see a variety of
characters, the character bai,
which means one hundred;
chu, which means to go out;
qi, seven; si, meaning four.
So there are characters here,
but there's no sentence here,
which is very frustrating
for a researcher.
However, it's interesting because
whoever put these together,
whether it was a forger, whether it
was someone who genuinely was trying
to collate some kind
of cartographic data.
They were looking at
something Chinese.
something that had Arabic text.
And you get this very
odd amalgam here.
The Map with Ship, again, also has
these kind of numbered toponyms
that again refer to very similar set
of places moving towards the east,
and if you look at them again,
there's this attribution
to the Saracens, to Arab
navigators, these remote islands,
cattigara [phonetic],
which you find in Ptolemy.
Again, a reference to animals
that would live in these regions.
Lioni marini, sea lions.
And then these islands connected
to the peninsula of the stags.
You can imagine these reindeer
running across remote corner
of Siberia and northeastern Asia.
Of course, what the media globbed
onto was the fact that this section
of the map looks just like the
Bering Strait, and if it looks
like the Bering Strait, it
must be the Bering Strait,
and I argued strenuously
against this,
and in fact going all the
way back to my PhD thesis,
I have a long history of arguing
that with cartography
things may look alike.
It doesn't mean they're
the same thing.
But if you go online, you'll see
this in a whole bunch of magazines
and newspapers, and I like
to show audiences this
because it's interesting.
You do see this ring of
islands, which look sort
of like the Aleutian Islands, but
we cannot make any firm statement
as to the identity of what this
map is referring to in terms
of present day cartography.
Another daughter, Fantina Polo, also
has her name on one of these maps.
This is a very odd map in terms
of its frame, the strange ellipse,
and again it has inscriptions, and
again it has a series of toponyms.
And it was this map that
struck me in a way as one
of the most interesting because
the toponyms when I looked
at them puzzled me
literally for several years.
I was like what is this because
it's Italian, Latinated Italian,
but some of the words were not
even remotely Latin or Italian,
and when I looked at them, well the
first was Zipangu, which is Japan.
That's how Marco Polo period
text referred to Japan.
That's not strange.
The first one, Serica,
that's just the word
for China, and Tartary, Tartaria.
But then toponym number three Uan
Scian, you'd say it in Italian,
and then the next one, To Qiu.
And then the next one, Da Han,
or in Venetian the C would
be pronounced H, Ta Can.
And then Focan.
And the final one, the eastern sea.
But I looked at those middle ones,
and I said those just sound very,
very strange to me, and
again I already had this idea
that the renderer of these maps was
trying to take something foreign
to him or her and put it
into some kind of Italian,
something that would be
understandable to them.
And it finally struck me that
the third one, the fifth one,
and the sixth one were Chinese,
and I only knew that by pure chance
because there's a famous
story of Fu Sang,
which some of you may know
about, it's this Chinese tale
of a Buddhist monk
that supposedly travels
to the distant reaches
beyond the ocean,
but the place names actually
are referred to sequentially
in the myth, so you have Uan Scian
[phonetic], which is Wen Shen
in Chinese, and that literally means
a tattooed body, like the Ainu,
a marked body, Chen means a body.
And then Da Han would be,
actually I explained it here.
Da Han would be the great country
of the Han, of the Chinese.
So again you're going in
order because according
to the original story
in the Liang Shu,
in fact there's this
progression of places going
to the distant northeast.
Wen Shen, the tattooed or marked
bodies that may refer to the Ainu.
Da Han wall [phonetic], the great
Han country, said to be east.
And then finally to the
distant east, you have Fu Sang,
and that Sang refers
to the mulberry tree.
So it's interesting that you
have this map that's attributed
to Marco Polo's daughter that has
these toponyms written in Italian,
written in Venetian dialect,
and yet they're referring
to a Chinese story,
a mythical story,
and that to me was
the most interesting.
Not in terms of proving a
voyage beyond the Pacific,
but just looking at sources.
And what's fascinating
is that this story
of Fu Sang was actually only
known in Europe in the 1700's.
A sinologist, a kind of strange
sinologist named Joseph de Guignes,
who some of you may know,
he believed that Chinese characters
were based on Egyptian hieroglyphs,
but he was a sinologist, and
he did understand Chinese.
He only found that text, the Fu
Sang text, the Liang Shu text,
he only found that in the 1700's,
and he presented it about 1761
in France, and he took the Chinese
names and Romanized them via French
through the French language.
So what's very strange is that
we see here it done in Italian.
And in fact these place names
became put onto maps in the 1700's.
This is a map, I forget the map
maker here, but he's actually drawn
across the bottom, let me see
here, he says [foreign language].
So it's like the root of the
Chinese to America in 458.
So obviously in the 1700's people
believed this tale as a true tale
of journeys across the Pacific.
But what's interesting is that the
Polo map suggested somebody had this
idea much earlier, had read
this Chinese story much earlier,
and had essentially brought
it to Europe much earlier.
So to me this was the most
interesting aspect of these maps,
a very strange synthesis of
Chinese and European sources.
The conclusions are
interesting since this first part
of the conference really is
about fact or fiction, and again,
when I wrote the book, and when
I was talking to the University
of Chicago about the book,
I said I really just want
to be the person examining
the contents.
I want to translate everything.
I want to draw some
analogies, like I just did.
I want to look at content, but it's
very hard to make fixed conclusions.
You have here some
interesting possibilities
that the content suggests.
You know, the book, my book
really looks at analysis
of the maps themselves, translation
of the text, again tries to put it
in context of other
cartographic work,
but it's not quite a
repeat of the Vinland map.
First of all, there are more
documents, which is interesting.
The other is that there's
connections between the two.
They use this sort of
same toponymic system,
sometimes the same
places are referred
to in one map and another map.
They're tied together by
supposedly all being penned
by Marco Polo's daughters.
They are also different
from the Vinland map
in that there's no single suspect,
at least that I was
able to identify.
Even Rossi himself I don't think
quite had the chops let's say
to crank all of these
out as a collection.
Also, it's not clear
what the motive is.
Usually when we look at forgeries
there may be a political motive,
a socioeconomic motive, just
a straight monetary motive.
You know, I am making these to sell.
And in fact it's interesting
in Rossi's history,
we don't have any record of him
trying to sell them to the Library
of Congress for example or sell
them to anyone else, so it's very,
very strange whoever created these
had some motive, but it's not really
in line with what we might see in
the history of other forgeries.
Here's a picture of the
Vinland map again as I talk
about my conclusions, and maybe
during the question session it would
be nice to sort of look at
what is the analogy or not.
Again, the Vinland map is
essentially written in one language,
has a fairly clear agenda,
one that was just elucidated
in the proceeding talk, and even the
cartography itself very explicitly
says look here up in
this portion of the map.
The Rossi maps obviously make lots
of allusions to the far northeast,
but there's never find of the
explicit claim, for example,
that Marco Polo reached America.
It's never said.
So it's a very kind of obtuse,
very obscure agenda in those maps.
So the conclusions that I do draw
in the book that these may be copies
from the 18th century of something
that was genuinely earlier
because certainly the handwriting
suggests something that was written
after the time of Marco Polo.
There's not been a lot
of testing of the inks.
There has been some
testing of the velum.
But these may be something where it
was genuinely a manuscript tradition
trying to preserve
genuinely anomalous maps,
but there are many oddities,
there are anachronisms in terms
of the representation, you
know, this far northeast
that doesn't appear on
any maps of this period.
But obviously I felt that there were
a number of distinctive features
which merited 13 years of my life to
study these maps, and then the sort
of last lesson that I like to say is
that the critics, for those of you
who plan to write books,
critics are never satisfied.
So when I presented this book,
and again if you read it,
it's very conservative I think.
Many people said it
wasn't speculative enough.
They said but look it looks
like the Bering Strait.
So they weren't satisfied.
Others of course said
that it's too speculative,
so that's a nice warning
for those of you
that do cartographical research.
Again, for me what was most
interesting is the content
and the fact that there's
probably a lot more work
to be done on these maps.
Thank you, and we'll have
questions at the end.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> John Hessler: Thank you, Ben.
We are now going to, you can see
that our cartographic
controversies are kind
of forcing their way
across the ocean here.
We first started with
the Vinland map.
It was trying to get to America.
Ben's maps are trying to cross
the Aleutian Islands and get here.
Our next talk is actually going
to get here, and it's going
to just prove that in fact that the
cartographic controversies are not
for European historians alone.
The curatorship that I hold is
the history of early Americas,
and we broadly can see that.
So our next speaker, Stephanie
Wood, is a Latin Americanist.
She is an expert in the
Natawala [phonetic] language.
Her dictionary, her
online dictionary,
is used by hundreds of
thousands of people.
She has also worked on Nawat
[phonetic] pictorial manuscripts.
We have this a little bit in common.
I spent the summer working
at the Bibliotheque Nationale doing
hyperspectral imaging on a lot
of map manuscripts from the
Aztec post-colonial period
that we have no idea who
made them and what they are.
And so she's going to talk about
a group of maps that you may not,
this crowd may not
have any knowledge of.
So, Stephanie, I'm just
going to let you do it.
[ Applause ]
[ Background Noise ]
>> Stephanie Wood:
Well, they so much.
It's wonderful to be back
at the Library of Congress.
I spent some months here in
1995 in the Hispanic division.
Almost took a job there, but
my husband is at the University
of Oregon, so it was hard
to be divided so distantly.
And I wanted to just thank John
Hessler and the Kislak Foundation
and in particular Arthur Dunkleman
[phonetic], who invited me
to be a part of this really
fun and interesting meeting.
I didn't realize, sorry, I thought I
was going to stand out as, you know,
really an oddball with these
particular manuscripts,
but now I don't think so so much.
So [laughter] these are manuscripts
that are in the Library of Congress
so you could take a look at them
yourself if you have some time
and if you have the interest.
The maps are, there
are I think 24 here.
I didn't put them all up,
but I put a large sampling
so you can get a sense
of the corpus.
There are more than
the ones that are here.
There are some still in Mexico, but
the ones that are here are found
in a court case, a criminal case of
forgery from the late 19th Century.
It turns out that a group
of 18 men were participating
under the leadership of a
Melecio Yanez from Puebla,
[foreign language], a
person of mixed heritage,
who worked with these
other men to make the maps
and associated land title
for indigenous communities
in the Puebla-Tlaxcala
area of central Mexico,
and at least 25 towns bought these
maps and the associated titles
and some have more than one.
So I don't know what happened.
Maybe they made a map and the town
said no, no, no, that's not right,
and so they made them
another one, I'm not sure.
I visited one of the towns
that has two, and they're still
in their archives and they are so
proud of these and love these maps,
so what I'm about to say I'm
glad no one is here from the town
because they have some oddities.
I'm going to be looking at, you
know, the nature of the corpus
in general, why would
people buy them.
I'm looking a lot at the content.
I'm a historian and not
a map specialist myself,
but also sort of the technique.
So my methodology in deconstructing
the maps is something I want
to make clear today.
And not just the maps but again
the titles, which are manuscripts
that include supposed
information about town founding,
declaration of the
boundaries, and so on.
We'll see a little bit more
about that in a minute.
So what is the nature of the maps?
There are a number of what I call
subsets, groups within the corpus
that have shared characteristics,
so this is one subset
where there are a lot of greens and
yellows, and across the landscapes
of the towns represented,
we have birds
and snakes and large human heads.
This is another group that has
the palette of browns largely,
buildings painted white, and so on.
And here's another group that
the cartographer really liked
to use sharp, notable angles.
So I'm thinking there were
several people who made the maps.
There was a fellow named
Manuel Tello who was pointed
out in the course case
as being the map maker,
but I think that among the 18 men
there must have been a few working
on this.
Maybe he taught some
others how to make maps,
and so there are multiple styles.
And so one of the things I work
with students is to identify
when you see a map that might
be part of a larger corpus
to see what is it about
that map that makes it seem
to fit in with that group.
So I put up here for you some
other maps of central Mexico,
and there's one from this
Puebla-Tlaxcala group.
By the way they were
made about 1870,
purporting to be colonial
Mexican maps,
and so I have some colonial maps
here, one from the 16th century
and two from the 17th and
one of these 1870 maps.
And I hope that you can
see which one it is.
Does anyone want to venture a guess?
It's the lower left here, so it has,
this is one of the green and yellow,
but it also has those buildings
painted white, and it's, you know,
it looks rather romantic, landscape
like compared to the others.
The upper left is the 16th century,
very much indigenous cartographic
example, and then the other two
from the 17th century on
the right, top and bottom.
So here's a closeup of the one
that was in the lower left.
This is not here in the
Library of Congress.
This one, a vendor of Rare
Books and Manuscripts,
contacted me in 2012 saying,
you know, what can you tell me
about this map, and right away I
said, oh, that looks like it fits
with this corpus of the Yanez-Tello
Workshop that I'm calling it.
Here's the document that's in the
court case here in the Library
of Congress that shows the
arrest record of Melecio Yanez,
who was sort of the ring leader and
Manuel Tello and some other men.
Vicente Poblano, Antonio
Guerrero, these are typical names
of urban dwelling, mixed heritage
men, probably came from Puebla.
Francisco Coca, now that
last name is in line
with an indigenous community elite
from one of the Townsend vaults,
so it's, so there's some involvement
of indigenous people in the making
of these maps for indigenous towns,
but it's largely not their work.
This is another document
in the court case,
which shows the profit motive if
you will and making these maps.
The man made maps and titles from
more than 20 communities as I said,
and in this case, for
example, made 15 visits
to one town to collect payments.
And for me this is a risky
behavior because for one thing
if you're doing something
surreptitious,
the authorities are
likely to see you if you're
around to different
towns collecting money.
Also I work on another workshop
from the valley of Toluca, Mexico,
where the collector was in fact
murdered by a town that was very fed
up with making these payments,
and the money was rather,
it was expensive, and it was
hard to get the money together.
And this document, another one,
they kept very meticulous records
of all the monies they collected
from the different towns
and who went and did
what, so it was very easy
for the criminal case
layer to figure this out.
I just show this one because it
mentions don Francisco Cahuantzi,
who was again an indigenous
person, an elite, and some relative
of his became governor of the stat
of Glasgow in the 19th century,
so it's really intriguing
to me who this man was,
but he was lesser known
than Prospero Cahuantzi,
who was the governor.
So I don't know a lot about
that particular fellow.
Here's an example of a map
and the accompanying titles.
For one particular town,
they had to pay 299 pesos,
a daily wage was a third of a peso,
so this is a lot of money for humble
and small indigenous
communities to come up with.
So they were, there was a monetary
motive to a large extent here.
The documents that go with the maps,
very fitting elements
are say a royal provision
that says this town has this
territory and we recognize it,
and then there is a process that
provides a protection of possession,
boundary survey, measurements,
and then result is a map.
Now that's the official colonial
administrative kind of record.
Now these have, in addition to those
faked elements of the town title,
they have some more things
that they have pulled
from the more indigenous
historical record tradition.
So portraits of town founders.
A code of arms.
A narrative of the town founding.
A narrative of the first
church and the use of Nahuati.
I'm not saying that, you
know, using Nahuati was fake.
It was an internal thing that
many towns had records in Nahuati,
the indigenous language
of the central Mexicans,
but for a colonial official
record to have that was unusual.
So here's an example
of one of these titles.
A town founder, supposedly the
portrait from the year 1623,
but his clothes immediately
convey that's not the case.
You know, if this is a copy
of something earlier, okay,
made in the 19th century perhaps,
but it claims to be
a [foreign language].
They use these true, you
know, original and so
on words all the time, which
when there is copy made,
it was always a true and loyal copy
would be stated, so they're bending
over backwards to say this is not
a copy, but it's not original.
And here's an example
of a coat of arms in one
of these bundles of town titles.
And they say specifically that
the town gave this coat of arms
to the viceroy, which is backwards
because in most communities
where they had a coat of arms
that was given to them by the kind
or the viceroy, you know,
that's the direction it went.
It went, you know,
authorities to the town
and then they proudly
would, you know,
show it in their community center.
But this one they said the
town gave this to the viceroy.
Well it's crazy, but
anyway, it's interesting.
So here we have the boundary
measurements, the standard kind
of thing, but the page
itself is very odd.
It says it's from 1758.
The handwriting says no it isn't.
There's a big stamp right
on top of the writing.
That's not a sealed paper, official
colonial sealed paper had the stamp
in the upper left corner, and
then you wrote next to it.
You didn't write over it.
And so this is, the
stamp has come later
and been put on top of the writing.
The orthography full of K's.
The letter K came into
Mexico in the 19th century.
It was definitely not there
in the colonial period
from many records I know of.
So, you know, it's
just very strange.
So another example of the boundary
survey, the royal provision,
supposedly from these
years, has three stamps.
You wouldn't have a
page with three stamps.
Usually just one in the
upper left-hand corner.
Typically too it would have then
some text that gave, with the stamp
that gave the years that
the paper was made and sold.
This is protection of possession
for one community, again full of K's
and so on, and misspellings
and other things.
This is a peculiar signature,
a hand print and a cross.
Sometimes, you know, we do see
crosses in colonial manuscripts,
not so many hand prints, and I
would just think that's very fun
if you're a, you know, a fingerprint
analyst, you could figure
out who this was, but of course
the person is now long dead,
but enjoyable.
Problematic dates.
This is one document that
says onyo day [phonetic] 1546,
the year of 1546 when it's not
at all the right handwriting
for that period or this statement
on a map that says, you know, 1760,
and again full of K's and so on.
And here a map, totally
original, from the town.
Maps didn't say totally original.
They only said, you know,
totally faithful to the original
when it was a copy, as we see
in the bottom example here.
Peculiar orthography, so again just
kind of sharing with you the methods
of deconstructing this syelo,
the word for sky, S, Y, E, L, O,
just unheard of spelling.
You know, maybe C and
S's were substituted,
but the I for Y with
the S just strange.
Eskritura with a K, no, no, never.
And so on.
So Eskribano Real y
publiko, this notary.
Notaries typically
abbreviated real y publiko,
they got so sick of writing.
Even the work escribano
was abbreviated,
so the whole thing would
be abbreviated here.
It's all spelled out like a
very big amateur might do,
but even that, it's just very rare.
A lot of these titles were tied with
ropes in legahos [phonetic] bundles,
and those ropes over
the years of being tied
and untied would create a lot of
wear, which this one page, you know,
looks, it looks something
like the wear that you see,
but this was burned in to make it
look like it was worn by robes,
and yet the page underneath is not
worn, and that would be strange.
So very curious, peculiar.
Here's another example of
an oddity, lined paper.
We didn't have lined paper
in the colonial period.
You go in the archives,
you won't find it.
So very 19th century
flavor right here.
And going back to those seals
that I already pointed out.
These are fabricated.
They misspell the word seal
itself, so, you know, duh,
but they also made two
or three different kinds,
and they stamped them
all over everything
in a kind of enthusiastic way.
So that's a problem.
Also, these stamps were
made for official paper
that you would write documents on.
Maps were not usually
stamped with these seals,
so we find that the maps have
the seals stamped all the way
around the edges, and
that's not done.
In looking back at the titles,
there was I think an effort here
to make them look old by making them
dirty, but smudging them with ink.
So we see a lot of that
on a lot of the pages.
Okay. I mentioned the
appearance, the use of Nawat.
There isn't a lot in these
manuscripts and maps,
but there are some examples, which
I the suggest the map makers wanted
to blend an authenticity
of Nawat community,
and this is their language, and,
you know, this is what they wrote,
but again it's poorly done.
It's by people who don't really
know the language very well,
they maybe know a few words,
so on this map we see it says
ninteopantzin tel tochantzin.
It's their church, but
it's our town, our home.
Which is a puzzling,
peculiar thing to say.
There may have been some kind
of dispute in this community
over whose church this was,
which town it pertained to,
but that was extremely rare
and unlikely, so I don't know,
whoever wrote that might not
really have realized even what they
were saying.
But I do want to say
that the paintings
of the churches are sometimes very
realistic as though, as I said,
these guys were itinerant.
They went to the towns
collecting money.
They also seemed to have
gone to the towns to look
for legitimate local detail
to work into the maps.
So the church here, the photograph
that I have is from the back,
so it's not going to look
identical to you maybe,
but it is the same church, so
that's kind of interesting.
On a couple of the maps we have a
founding couple prostrate in front
of the church, crawling toward it.
And that's very unusual.
I've never seen it before anywhere
else, and if you know of examples
of this, I'd like to
understand the origin,
where did they get this image,
and it's because it appears twice.
See here's another one.
Having a founding couple,
male and female,
is an indigenous Mexican
characteristic
of early maps and manuscripts.
You know, we talk about
our founding fathers.
They had their founding mothers and
fathers, which is kind of refreshing
for the gender balance, but they
very rarely crawled like, or,
you know, lay down in
front of the church.
This is very typical, a couple
sitting in a cave or in a building.
This is the usual founding couple
arrangement, male and female, yes.
And here's another one.
So these are legitimate 16th century
examples that I'm showing you
of founding couples,
early ancestors and so on.
That's typically the
way they appeared.
Okay, also on these maps we
have these talking heads,
which I showed early on,
and what I didn't say is
that they have speech scrolls
coming out of their mouths,
and that's an indigenous
cartographic tradition.
You put people on the landscape.
You put words coming
out of their mouths.
The indigenous local elite was
called aglactowani [phonetic],
one who has the speech, the speaker.
And in this case, this one talking
head on the upper left is saying,
you know, the patron is San
Antonio, so he's speaking
about the patron saint
of the local church.
So that's kind of interesting.
And to have large heads on
the manuscripts was something
in the region known on manuscripts.
I showed two examples
from the Puebla area
where large heads were
put on the landscape.
It's pretty unique to this region.
I haven't seen it a lot in
other parts of central Mexico,
but I wondered if the map makers had
seen these other earlier manuscripts
and got the idea to put
these large heads out there
from these other manuscripts.
And here's another example.
The large head on the upper left
here, he's saying, the father,
the father, the father, which is odd
because usually it was the father,
the son, the holy spirit.
And so again they've written this in
Nawat, really not sure probably how
to say the father, the son,
and holy spirit in Nawat,
so they just repeated the father,
which is, again, humorous for me,
but I can see they were
earnestly trying here
to put something believable and
authentic seeming on the landscape.
I got two other examples of people.
You more often would see a bust
or a whole body than just the head
in many other manuscripts.
So I have shown you some heads.
They did exist, but this
is more common in a way.
Okay, another feature from
another map example on the left,
we have a comet from 1816.
And I wonder if that comet was
maybe seen in the 16th Century,
Duran corex [phonetic], you know,
because it has some similarities
in the way it's represented,
but again I really don't
know all the sources
that these map makers had for
trying to infuse their maps
with some authenticity and
typical indigenous traditions.
There was a definite interest
in celestial phenomena,
and comets were, texts are full of
references to comets, so, you know,
it kind of fits in that way.
One of the titles that accompanied
the maps has a reference in fact
to the Aztec empire, so that's
kind of interesting again
that they were thinking about,
you know, trying to reach back
and connect to pre-Columbian
and early colonial times
in various ways, and then
there's a reference to 1578 here,
and definitely the hand
is not 16th century.
One of the manuscripts has
an eagle with a serpent,
and if any of you know the Mexican
flag, you know we have the eagle
on a cactus with a serpent.
And so again maybe they pulled
this from an earlier manuscript
and put it on the map to
give that Aztec flavor.
They also put serpents, and
in this case tigre, a tiger,
which was really [inaudible]
the word in the Nawat
for any kind of man-eating wild cat.
So you get, I really think they
mean jaguar here because serpents
and jaguars were very prominent
in pre-Columbian Aztec iconography
and so I also have a 16th century
map that shows a tiger on a hill,
which is sort of a
glyphic representation
of the word Tehuantepec,
which was wild cat hill.
And so again maybe they saw some
earlier maps, and they got the idea,
oh, let's put all over the landscape
snakes and tigers and things.
So here are some other legitimately
colonial maps with snakes on them,
so you can see where they
might be trying to recall that.
Now this gets more like
Ripley's Believe it or Not.
They have drawn and
painted in some what appear
to be pre-Hispanic sculptures
in this one town in particular,
and the one on the left, you know,
it does look as though maybe there's
something like this in the town,
and I want to go there and
see if they have any kind
of sculpture that looks like that.
The one on the right
is really very strange.
It looks like an alien
from outer space I think,
but nothing I've seen like that.
And also, you know, again like
with this mysterious Ripley's kind
of flavor, an eagle of what they say
here in the text to be 37-1/2 pounds
that could life up a
sheep and carry it away.
So super interesting.
And here's some more
details to research locally.
I haven't gone yet to
this particular town.
There's so many of them,
it's going to take a while
but there are a number of
really mysterious details
on this Acapetlahuacan map, you
know, a man hanging by his feet.
You know, a woman lying
bloody and dead.
Another head suspended from
a branch and some skeletons,
so this town had a really
colorful history apparently.
I just really can't
wait to learn more.
Now aside from trying to
reach back and bringing
in indigenous traditions, these
map makers I think also tried
to infuse their maps with a
semblance of cartographic modernity.
And so they have these features,
like, you know, a compass showing,
you know, the cardinal points.
The slightly different one
to the next is again is though
there were multiple hands involved
in making these maps, and
some port north on the top,
and some put east on the top.
So the indigenous tradition
was to put east
on the top and European north.
So that's something
further to research
and who might have made
which type of compass.
And then this example
on the right is from one
of our Pueblo-Tlaxcala maps,
and it has [foreign language].
I mean that's just, I've never
seen that, and it's fascinating.
And that kind of language
is probably familiar to some
of you who are cartographers.
And on the left I can show you
that we do have some colonial maps
with these kinds of
cartographic modernity beginning
to appear in the 18th century.
And so it's not unusual exactly, but
it's kind of an exaggerated example.
So that fascinated me.
So European influences do, you know,
creep their way into these maps.
In particular, I find it in the
cartouches, in the, you know,
the one on the left here,
it was incredibly elaborate,
beautiful example from
a European authored map.
On the right are two examples
from our Puebla-Tlaxcala group,
which are, you know,
not so elaborate,
especially the lower right is very
simple, but the upper right tries
to be more detailed and pleasing.
Okay, just to put this one example
I'm sharing with you in a context,
we have known today eight title
and map manufacturing workshops
in Mexican history, and so I
wanted to show you another example
to give you a sense of how the
Yanez Tello group compares.
Am I doing okay on time?
Okay. So just a few
slides of this other group,
which is led by a fellow named
Ramirez de Arellano, and these maps
and titles were made
around the year 1900.
Again, purporting to be colonial.
In this case, almost all of them
have dates something like 1639
or 1609, and so they're made on
cloth some of them and on paper.
And they too have this emphasis on
the cartouche that starts out mapa,
map, and so on, and they're all
indigenous towns in central Mexico.
Some of these are copies, and
so the styles vary a little bit,
but they're pretty similar as a
whole as you look at the group,
and the legend there, map, de
las tierras map of the lands
that pertain to such
and such a place.
They have certain repeating
characteristics in the handwriting,
the D and the E being combined,
the V for U. They almost
all have a town founder,
a single person on the landscape.
At the center of town,
he's dressed quite the same
in almost all these maps, holding
his hat down and his hand up.
I think this pointing is an effort
to make him the platawane
[phonetic], the one who could speak,
the local ruler, because
they often showed
in 16th century manuscripts a person
with the voice also
would point the finger.
So I think that's what's
happening here.
Interestingly, in 2009 the town,
one of the towns that has one
of the lienzos [phonetic], canvas
maps, they gave a presentation
on 400 years of the validity of
their town map, and I couldn't go,
but I was really intrigued to note
how the town really embraces it
as a legitimate valid
map of their town.
And so I had done a little looking
around at some of the details
on their map, and I have been able
to identify four different place
names that are in fact local.
So again, I think the makers of this
group went to the town and asked,
you know, tell me, you know,
let's walk over the landscape
and you identify everything for me,
and they would work
that into the map.
So in that sense you can see
how the town would embrace it.
Yeah, this represents our town.
And here are four more examples
of this particular corpus,
and they're slightly different
though they have these recurring
characteristics that help
us identify them as a group.
They also are customized.
So again they've been to the town.
They've asked the local people.
They tried to put the mountains
where they're supposed to go.
If there was a body of water,
they tried to put it in there.
They also incorporate a few more
indigenous cartographic details
such as if there's a road or a path
that is marked with footprints,
which was a pre-Columbia,
early colonial indigenous way.
And water is a current that
throws off shells as it goes,
and they tried to use that
method for replicating rivers.
Okay, so to summarize and figure out
what our takeaways are from looking
at these kinds of mass-produced
maps and manuscripts.
I want to urge that we not
dismiss them outright as forgery,
so we're looking at fact or fiction.
For me it's fact and fiction.
It's more fitting to say
that these are contrived.
In other words, they've taken
local input to make a vision
of a community that fit what the
town itself might recognize even
if they've also tried to pretend
it's early, old, which would,
if it ended up in the courts
perhaps help the community defend
their lands.
Towns desperately need a
documentation, so they were ready
to pay these exorbitant prices
to get maps for their towns,
to fulfill that need
to defend their towns.
And it wasn't such a
level playing field.
In the colonial period and
especially in the 19th century,
there were a number of laws
attacking group-held lands,
and indigenous community
lands were held by the town.
Use of parcels was individualized,
but as a whole land
was held by the group.
So in the reforms of the
second half of the 19th century
that attacked group held
lands, which were mainly aimed
at the Catholic church, they
affected indigenous communities.
Then Maximillian of Hapsburg
came in and reversed that,
but then we had a dictatorship,
Porfirio Diaz [phonetic],
in the late 19th century
Mexico, where he returned
to attack a group-held land, and it
was when it was in that last quarter
of the 19th century, last
third of the 19th century
when indigenous lands were really
alienated more than ever before
and large estates were being
built up more than ever before.
So it was tough, and towns were
really desparate for some documents
to defend their communities.
So I call that the, you know, the
social versus the legal context,
and as I said, there were
eight such workshops,
so this is a huge phenomenon.
There was a recent book by Karina
Olds called "Forging the Past"
in which she looks at medieval
and Renaissance manuscripts
to understand some of the
complexities of forgery,
and one quote I just thought
I would share with you here
from her recent book
is forgeries were not,
at least from the perspective of
their perpetrators, outright lies.
They were rather a recovery of
a deeper, more essential truth,
that had been waylaid somehow, or in
the case of indigenous communities,
maybe they never had documents
to defend their territories.
And yet I don't want to be
speculative or not enough,
I want to say that science is
also important, and so we need
to take science to our
study of these manuscripts.
We have to have a methodology
that allows us to recognize
when a new map or manuscript
emerges.
Does it fit in some of
these known corpuses?
Does it have that kind of
style, that orthography,
terminology, handwriting.
We even need to look more at the
paper or the cloth and so on,
and we need to seat the historical
context that produced the map
and also the history
that it conveys.
We don't want to undermine
their validity
for the indigenous communities,
but we can't be nave either,
so we have both fact and fiction.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> John Hessler: Well, I
want to call our speakers
up for a question session if
we'd like to take some questions.
One of things that I found
interesting about all three
of our papers here is
this combination of the,
both the cross-cultural context in
both post and pre-modern elements
that are moving into both
of these, all of these maps.
Any questions?
John?
>> Yeah, I have one for Stephanie.
I have a question and a comment.
[Inaudible] conceptual Mexico and--
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Was genuine civic pride
that they really wanted
to show off their ancestry as
well as making land claims.
And then the second comment, just
a comment, that crouching position
that you showed in that map, I've
seen that in a number of places
with people going on pilgrimage
to pilgrimage destinies.
So if these towns were pilgrimage
destinies, I've watched people
down like that say going into San
Miguel del Milagro in Tlaxcala
and you know Tepaoc
[phonetic] and so forth.
I'm wondering if they're saying, you
know, this is place of pilgrimage,
and we are going to the shrine
of our patron saint and so forth.
>> Stephanie Wood: Thanks John.
Yeah, two really good
comments and questions.
First of all, pride in ancestry
I do think enters into it,
certainly in legitimate internally
made manuscripts and maps,
and these [inaudible] weren't so far
removed from the indigenous heritage
that they might, and again, because
a couple of them are indigenous,
koka [phonetic] and kawansene
[phonetic], I think they did,
they were probably in line with
this not just for the money
but for the pride and the
ability to provide communities
with something they
desperately needed.
It's interesting to me that they
don't try to replicate the genealogy
across the landscape,
which is very common
on many indigenous authored maps.
Putting people on the
landscape is huge in,
you know, age-old traditions.
And often those people
are ancestors,
you know multiple generations
of ancestors.
I haven't seen that
yet in that group,
but I think it wouldn't be
too surprising to find it,
but they were a little bit
removed maybe from that tradition.
The people on the ground, you
know, pointing toward the church,
I agree with you, it's the
pilgrimage concept definitely is
worth exploring.
I've been Tepeyac, for instance,
the virgin of Guadalupe shrine,
where people get off the bus a
kilometer or two kilometers away
and crawl the rest of the way,
and they get to the church bloody
and their clothing
torn and everything.
So, yeah, it really
does recall that.
I mean the whole thing of
prostrating oneself before a cross
or an altar, and there's plenty
of examples of that in, you know,
across Europe and in Mexico.
I just haven't seen it
on these kinds of maps,
but it's not a surprise
exactly, you're right,
it's just unusual on the maps.
Thanks. Thanks John.
>> John Hessler: John,
the other John.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
>> Stephanie Wood: Hey.
>> What was the result of
the attempt by these people
to hold onto their lands.
In other words, you're
looking at these communities,
what did they lose in the process?
Were they successful, even
if these are fraudulent maps,
did they indeed lose property based
on porfirioto [phonetic]
and [inaudible] land?
>> Stephanie Wood: Yeah, I think the
Puebla-Tlaxcala region did find the
perimeters of their territories
encroached upon increasingly
in that period, but they
still held the town center,
and in the second group I
showed they were especially,
and I didn't point it out, but that
whole Ramirez de Arellano set has
the fundo la galle
[phonetic] marked off.
So in the colonial period, the crown
recognized a minimum town base,
and it wasn't just for the buildings
and the church, but it was farmed,
and I've got lots of
manuscripts that show that.
And I do think in the
Puebla-Tlaxcala area they
at least protected that
much a lot of the time.
There are some towns, I
studied, one of the maps I showed
from Wahaka [phonetic] whereby the
town, only the mere core was left.
The haciendas took a lot
of it away, but in the end,
in that particular case,
the church gave back,
when their lands were attacked,
they gave back some of the land
that they had accumulated
to the town.
I think that's a rare thing.
I don't think that was
common, but anyway,
whether the maps were
really effective
in defending the territories,
I'm not so sure
because they were denounced
as forgeries,
and you know there was a trial,
and that happened a lot with many
of the, many of the
workshops we've identified.
The leaders were sent to jail,
or one as I said was murdered,
and then his widow was investigated
because she continued going
around trying to get the money that
the husband couldn't end up getting.
It didn't really matter
to them sometimes
like the sacatel cotu [phonetic]
maps that are still in one
of the towns in the region, they
love them, and they're proud
of them, and I don't think they've
ever taken them to use in court.
So they had, it's the social context
for them that is the most important,
but anyway, I think a study of
late 19th century landholding
in the region would really
be helpful to see, you know,
just the situation for these
particular communities.
Thanks and good to see you.
>> John Hessler: There we go.
>> I've got a question for Ben.
What do you know about
Rossi's professional life
or his possible motivation
for amassing this collection,
which I think you said
comprised much more than 14 maps?
>> Ben Olshin: That's
a very good question.
In the book, I sort of give a
little bit of background of him,
and I guess you may know that the
present owner is a direct descent
of Rossi.
Rossi's professional life was
interesting in that he was a tailor,
and he was not highly educated.
And that itself is kind of an
interesting point of contention
because I think there's a lot of
bias that people think that somebody
who doesn't have a lot of formal
education wouldn't be interested
in history.
But he is partially just
because he's Italian,
he's strongly identifies as
an Italian, so he's interested
in history generally
of the Italians.
But also he's a tailor,
and yet he makes the claim,
particularly in a letter
to the Library of Congress
that he's descended from
somebody named Julio de Rossi,
who was connected directly
with Marco Polo.
So, you know, it's very
difficult to verify that claim.
That's one of the projects that
still has to be done genealogically.
But apparently then he says,
you know, he's just a tailor.
He's interested in history; however,
he's amassed these
manuscripts while in Italy.
He comes to the United States and
then wants to have them examined.
I mean he brings them literally
right here to have them examined.
So that's kind of his personal
history, but in the documentation,
and there's not a lot of
correspondence that survives
from him, but there's nothing
that sort of indicates again
that he had a particular agenda
other than kind of an amateur
in the positive sense of an
amateur, you know, a lover of stuff,
to find something else about them.
And that's one of the frustrating
things because I kept looking
for a hint that he was trying
to make money out of them
or that he wanted to
make some strong claim.
Really the strongest claim is
that he's descended
from this Julio Rossi.
Is that possible?
Absolutely, but with
a name like that,
it's going to be very
hard to determine.
And then when he passes away, what's
interesting is the maps then go
to an uncle, Louis Rossi, and
then finally to the current owner.
So it's kind of odd that he even
in death he doesn't make a sort
of strong effort to have
them preserved or anything.
When I came across them,
they literally were sitting
in just the drawer in
this house in Houston.
So kind of a long answer to
your story, to your question.
Nothing in Rossi's history
really suggests any kind
of useful information at this point
about the actual origins
of the map, etc.
>> John Hessler: One of the
things about the map that came
to the Library and when the group
of things came to the Library
and Ben said they were
analyzed, and we'll pull this
out when we show it tomorrow,
the FBI crime lab is the people
who did the investigation.
And J. Edgar Hoover,
there's correspondence,
that he's very worried
about this map
as being a national security issue
because if it does in fact show
that the Chinese or Marco Polo
or someone knew about America,
this would overturn western history,
and so there's a letter here
form J. Edgar Hoover announcing
that they are going to do
everything they can to study it.
And so it's kind of a fascinating,
the power of maps really
in this collection, in
the Vinland collection
and with Stephanie's workshops,
you can see the amazing power
of these images in a cultural and
legal sense that the authenticity
and truth of them doesn't
really matter.
It's just they have
these profound effects.
>> Ben Olshin: And we have to do
whatever we can to stop the idea
that either Catholics or Chinese
came here early on obviously.
>> A question for [inaudible].
>> John Hessler: Just
wait for the mic.
[ Background Noise ]
>> A question for Kirsten Seaver,
could you expand a little bit more
on your description of
Father Fischer's relationship
to the Vinland map and what motive
he might have to commit a forgery
and why a researcher of his stature
would do something like that?
>> Kirsten Seaver: You mean what
propelled me to research it or?
>> No, I thought at the end
of your talk you implied
that Father Fischer was the
creator of the Vinland map.
>> Kirsten Seaver: Yes, uh-huh.
>> And what was his motive?
What do you think his motive
might be and why would
such a professional researcher like
Father Fischer commit that forgery?
>> Kirsten Seaver:
It's very difficult
to explain Father Fischer's
personality unless you have read all
his writings, but essentially he
was an extremely Arodite [phonetic]
and at the same time naive
person, and he had a kind
of a fixed framework of thinking.
Once he had hit upon an idea
an become convinced about it,
such as that the Norse had
left a cartographic trail,
there was no budging him,
really no budging him.
And so in his old age, he was in
a situation where he had retired.
The Nazis had taken over Austria
and of course Germany first.
They were persecuting Catholic
priests, which is what he was,
which is why he was given refuge
at Wolfegg, and they were trampling
on some of the things that
were dearest to his heart,
and that was the truth of
cartographic history and the Norse.
I mean he knew that the Norse
were the Norse from the far north.
That had nothing to
do with what was going
on in the so-called greater Germany.
He was an educated
cartographic historian.
Then in the mid-1930's, he
had completed his magna opus
on the Ptolemaic maps in the Vatican
library, early Ptolemaic maps,
and the book was reviewed
by Leo Bogrov [phonetic],
who didn't like it at all, and
Fischer was absolutely crushed.
This was the low point in his
life, with the Nazis without
and then Leo Bogrov's
review in front of him.
And he got ahold of an old
manuscript that he could use,
and he made in his quiet moments
of his life, he made a map,
which he was convinced at one
time actually existed in one form.
He never made it for sale.
He had no personal property
as a Jesuit, so at some point
when he died it would
have floated out there,
and he was sure the Nazis
would have had to pick it
over in their own peculiar
fashion, and he put in this riddle.
As I said, he would have been
appalled had he known what happened
to it afterwards.
He was a very strange man.
The Vinland map is a
very strange production.
It is a product of his
old and unhappy life.
[ Background Noise ]
>> John Hessler: Anyone else,
we've got time for a couple more.
If otherwise, we can
break for lunch.
There's Arthur up there.
[ Background Noise ]
>> For Stephanie, this
series of maps is really part
of an old tradition of forgery
in Mexico and other places
to support indigenous land claims.
Maybe you could talk a little
bit about that tradition and also
about the type of social cohesion
in a community that would coalesce
to pay for, hide, and contribute to
the manufacture of this vast amount
of information and kind of one would
imagine in secret, I mean in secret
from the Mexican authorities
or the [inaudible].
>> Stephanie Wood:
Yeah, thanks Arthur.
Good to see you again.
Yeah, with eight workshops we've
now identified producing maps
and manuscripts to defend indigenous
communities we know is a massive
tradition, and we're trying to
understand each group is unique
in itself in its approach and so on,
but we have for instance
primordial titles as they're called,
which are written in indigenous
languages or which really try hard
to suggest they came internally
from the communities involved,
and yet because now
we've identified so many
of them we can see they
have recurring elements
that suggest mass production,
and yet, again,
a real effort to include local
detail, and the social cohesion
in terms of acquiring
these kinds of things
that people would come together.
It was the leadership was
really a crucial element there.
Leaders had sometimes benefited
personally from the stories
that were told because their
ancestors would be featured.
Some titles include testaments of
town leaders, ancestors, and so on,
so they would urge the community,
you know, this is really important,
we need this, we need to
raise funds to buy this,
and they were often doing that
for other purposes too, you know,
for religious festivals, so in the
Puebla-Tlaxcala area for instance,
it was the fescales, the
indigenous community leaders,
who were associated with the
church, who were doing a lot
of the fundraising I think for
buying these kinds of things.
And you can just see
it in the way the town,
the towns still do embrace these
even though they very often can't
read them anymore, and they don't
even really know what they say.
There might be one or two people
who can read them and explain
to the town, so I went
to [inaudible],
which had that 400th anniversary
of the validity of our manuscript.
I went, every couple
years they handed
from one town manuscript
guardian to the next,
and they have a big ceremony,
and they have a princess.
And they have a long
recitation they read in Nawat
that most people don't
understand it anymore.
And they get out, they
truck out their lienzo,
and everybody walks around it.
And they want the youth
to see it and know it,
and this is our town,
and this is our charter.
And this is really important to us,
and so everybody nods
and goes along with it.
Anyway, and they also reject.
They don't want to hear any of
the scientific analysis of it.
So am sympathetic, I
really am toward them,
but then I also, it's awkward.
I'm not quite sure
how to deal with that.
I have a book on this that I've
been developing for a long time
because there are so many
different interesting groups,
and they have such
interesting stories.
But I've been worried that
people will see it as an attack
on indigenous community landholding,
which I don't feel it's an attack.
I mean some communities
will say we're very glad
to know what you have
to tell us here.
We don't want to be
naive either, you know,
so we want to know what this is.
Even if we like it, we
want to know it's origin.
So that's a complicated,
roundabout answer.
I hope I got to what
you were looking for.
>> John Hessler: So
any final questions?
Wes?
>> For Kirsten Seaver, you
alluded to this at the beginning,
but I was a little confused.
So if you could hit this again.
Father Fischer's manuscript was
created by him, remind us again,
remind us again how it was then
discovered and reintroduced
into the world in the 1950's
or whenever that happened.
>> Kirsten Seaver: Oh, you mean the
history of how it ended up at Yale.
>> Yes.
>> Kirsten Seaver: Now that's
a very interesting history
because there was a book dealer,
an antiquarian book dealer
from Massachusetts, who went
to Switzerland and linked
up with Italian book
dealer who had long operated
in Switzerland as well as in Spain.
His wife was Spanish.
And picking over what was said at
the time about the purchase and what
in fact happened over time, this was
a collusion to make money, you know,
sort of gradually, by
passing the manuscript
on through various channels and
making it look like a coincidence
that the Vinland map, the tarter
relation, and somehow the holes
in the Speculum Historiale in the
old dilapidated binding all matched.
Well actually I've looked at the
thing, and there's only one hole
that matches, and that
is one that looks
like it's going straight
through like that.
This is all very peculiar.
The way in which the two
so-called sister texts ended
up at Yale is also very
strange because it has to do
with antiquarian book deals that
sort of went back and forth with,
you know, one person sells
it, the other one buys it
and then sells it back
to the next person again,
and it was all done
to make it look legit.
This is just a snake operation from
start to finish by the time it got
out of Father Fischer's hands.
My guess is that after he died
and the Stella Matutina Library
was taken over by the Nazis,
either a German soldier
stole it, you know,
it looked like all might be money,
or a liberation soldier
stole it, who knows.
But in 1957, all kinds
of stuff surfaced
because then the lid was off.
You could then sell
loot from the war,
and that's when it
all began to happen.
>> John Hessler: Well,
thank you everyone
for coming to the morning session.
We will break for lunch
and resume back here
at 1:00 for the Carta Marina.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.